[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author on the new york
times is my co-host today also my
daughter we'll be taking your questions
about life and money and relationships
and careers we talk about all of it here
on the ramsey show every day open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five diego starts us
off in phoenix arizona hi diego welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you guys doing today
better than i deserve what's up
hi so i'm 26 i have my bachelor's i want
to go to medical school i want to do a
debt free i've heard you talk about it
before on the show to go through like
the military
see like what other programs that they
offer um i tried going through them i
got disqualified um so i like i don't i
really like don't want to go into all
this debt but like it's just so time
consuming and on top of that i live with
my parents like i'm 26 like i want to
move out but but it seems like like i
don't know how i can do it without going
into debt you know because i want to go
to medical school like i'm ready to go
like i'm going to do this master's um
in august that that will give me a an
entry away into medical school so it's
just like a nine nine-month
master's program but to do that i need
to go into all this debt so i don't know
i don't know what what what i could do
you know
yeah diego it's a great question i feel
like
this is one we get
you know quite often especially whether
it's medical school or law school and i
think different
situations different schools have
different routes and of course it's a
very it's it's very rare and dave i
obviously would love your take on it
because you talk to people more than i
do with this scenario but
but what i know diego is that there have
been ways that people have found a way
not just to pay cash but they've done
things within the medical community or
they were part of
um you know
not not a fellowship but some type of
program that actually helps them pay
their way through and i feel like i hear
more often
that happening more in the law school
spectrum
um but dave have you
for medical school specifically
um there's a couple things that are
going on uh number one i want to go back
and address the phrase you said this is
so time consuming let me tell you what's
time consuming paying off 250 000 in
debt that's time consuming
okay so yeah you need to spend the time
and and the effort and that is the big
deal is to spend the time and the effort
on the front end there's a couple of
angles i would tell you to look at
one is where you get accepted to medical
school is very very important in the
equation because medical school is not
unlike other forms of higher education
in that some of that is 4 and 5x what
the other one costs
and so you know there is the cheaper
version and by the way i don't remember
ever asking a doctor where he went to
school
i just asked him if he could fix that
broken thing on me you know that's all i
wanted to know
and so uh and if he convinced me he
could then were there i never really
asked for credentials did you go to
uh you know a big-time med school or a
little-known med school i didn't ask
uh now obviously uh you can learn some
things in some places you can't learn at
other places and those sorts of things
but anyway so school selection just like
it is in undergrad is very important the
second thing you can look for is the md
phd program
uh the most famous one is over at duke
but there are several schools around the
country that have those and that's
basically where you get on staff
at the school and do some teaching some
undergrad teaching some grad level teach
you know grad level teaching type stuff
like graduate assistant type teaching
and since you're a staff member you get
free or near free tuition
very it's like getting a fellowship
though it's very rare it's very hard to
get in you know one in a hundred one in
whatever get it the second thing i would
do is i would pick up ramsey personality
uh christina ellis's book confessions of
a scholarship winner
what christina did was she managed to
apply for and get enough scholarships
that she got a half a million dollars in
scholarships
what yeah she did yeah that'll pay for
your med school dude okay so you need to
do what she did in that sense because
she ended up going getting her undergrad
and then went to vanderbilt for her grad
paid cash for all of it had money left
over uh and she's on our team now she's
a brand new ramsey personality but
before she came here she wrote a book
that's a was a bestseller called
confessions of a scholarship winner the
secrets that helped me win 500 000 in
free money for college how you can too
so that that type of stuff is this type
of material you need to be
rolling around in all day long the last
thing i will tell you and again this is
all just needle in a haystack stuff but
dude all you gotta do is find one
yeah and you're there because you don't
have to this does not have to be a um a
policy for the united states of america
this is
diego just got to do it just diego
that's the only guy's got to do it all
right so for your sake anyway
now a lot of the large pharmaceutical
companies
and large hospital companies are
desperate to have doctors
like them
and that includes future doctors and so
they some of them have
scholarship or work for hire type
programs meaning that you can talk to a
large hospital corporation and promise
to work for them
in a different setting maybe at a
reduced rate for several years uh but
you know you can go to an uh an
underserved area an inner city area a
rural area where they're having trouble
getting docks to park
and you go there and serve for three
years afterwards you get paid to do that
but in return for making that promise in
advance it's a modern day indentured
servant program you you get free medical
school paid for by them so that's the
type of stuff i'm looking for is all of
that worth it well you've just got to
weigh it out but i can tell you this
christina talks about she probably made
a thousand dollars an hour applying for
scholarships
so i mean if she had what 50 000 hours
you know in the thing so that'd be
that'd be a hundred dollars an hour you
know or five thousand hours would be
would be a thousand dollars an hour that
she got and she's she's amazing oh yeah
i know christina's absolutely incredible
i don't know like the scholarships
in the medical yeah but these were not
tied to anything she used them for grad
no she did but i'm saying for diego yeah
uh how specific yeah like are they
specific for medical i don't know
they're very again anything this
graduate level is harder to get than
undergrad yes yes a lot of undergrad out
there laying around and so yeah you're
saying all this is a needle in haystack
and sure it is but
what i know is even being on this show
and talking to people around the country
people have done it like they'll come up
to me in a book signing line or
something like oh yeah i went to medical
school debt-free
yes i always ask because it's some kind
of program like this right it takes a
little bit of that creativity like when
debt is not an option in your life and
you said i'm not whether it's medical
school or credit card debt you have to
find a new way of looking it's not just
this automatic so it does take some
creativity but this is not work
it's not getting in the drive-through
and getting a starbucks right you're
gonna have to this is not cookie cutter
i mean there's not one on every corner
right you're gonna have to scratch and
claw and dig and turn over rocks until a
crawdad runs out you don't know what
that is but there you go i know what a
crawdad is i know he doesn't but diego
where's diego from phoenix no but
there's crawdads in phoenix
you think i don't know is there in
louisiana they're crayfish so i don't
know
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so how's the resolutions going
if you're like most people you hit them
hard in january and you're starting to
run out of steam if you hadn't already
why because you're trying to do it all
on your own and you don't have a proven
plan that's step by step to help you
make it happen
if you really want to do this stuff if
you really want to get control of your
money don't do it alone
get the support the accountability you
need by joining a financial peace
university class
you can go through the proven money plan
with other people who will help you stay
motivated they'll encourage you they'll
also hold you accountable that's what
your friends will do and they'll be your
new friends and many of them will be
friends for life
because they're trying to do the exact
same like thing you're doing getting out
of debt building wealth being
outrageously generous
and right now there's hundreds of
financial peace university classes
getting started in person and online
so no more lame resolutions make 2022
the year you take control of your money
and uh don't do it alone find a
financial peace university class get
started with a free trial at
ramseysolutions.com
fpu
com
ramseysolutions.com
fpu jacobs in chattanooga hi jacob
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey rachel how are you guys
great man what's up
so my wife and i are 27 years old we
just finished baby step three and are
moving into baby step four way to go
yeah we're excited um so we we've sat
down with the smart investor in
chattanooga
started laying out our numbers and
talking to him about
investing and our goals for retirement
and after chatting with him we kind of
left discouraged rather than encourage
and i know baby step 456 is supposed to
be kind of moving into this exciting
dream for the future have vision
we just left the conversation feeling
kind of defeated a little bit
when we used your online platform for
investing the number that it was giving
us even at a low
percentage was way higher than what he's
given us and
we're just feeling discouraged and kind
of defeated not knowing what to do next
so jacob is it is it that you're
discouraged that when you're looking at
specifically investing or when you're
looking kind of your situation with four
five and six there's just once you do
everything and lifestyle there's not a
lot of money left like what specifically
is discouraging just the investing part
um a little bit of both so basically
my wife is we have a 10 month old my
wife is
working part-time from home staying with
him
and
so
our take-home pay is is
about 4 500 a month
so we don't have a ton to throw towards
investing in towards the college fund
and the house but
we still feel hopeful that we've created
room in our budget we we live
pretty uh below our mean so we feel like
we have a good amount of money each
month to still throw at those things
okay stop a second stop a second see if
you put 15 percent of your income in
baby step four and your income 75 000 a
year
why are you not going to be wealthy i
don't understand
we are our incomes only uh forty five
hundred dollars a month is just under
sixty thousand a year take home pay
which puts you at about seventy or
seventy five thousand gross
what's your gross
our gross is about 50 right now dude you
can't add
your your take-home pay is 50.
4 times 12 is 48. you said you take home
4 500 a month but his wife
no he says what you said it's part-time
as well
right right my wife my life's working
part-time
okay so what did you not tell me 4 500
take-home pay-per-month did you tell me
that
yes sir multiply that by 12 for me
12s are hard okay
it's 54 000
which means your gross rev your gross
income before taxes is north of 70.
it might be 68. does that okay okay
let's just let's just time out for a
second jacob tell me what what like does
that make sense or you is there some is
there another piece of this puzzle that
we're missing or or
i just want to get on the same track
with you
yeah it makes sense i mean the math
makes sense to me obviously all right so
if you take 15
of your gross
income
you're going to be wealthy if you invest
that in good growth stock mutual funds
do you have a match at work
no sir we don't okay
and and that's assuming you never get a
raise
right and of course you're going to get
a raise of course your household income
is going to go up over time
and when you get and when you get the
house paid off you're going to dump even
more money in it so i mean you're you're
not going to be a millionaire in four
years
but we
didn't tell you that uh you're going to
be a millionaire in 15 years but i'll
say this jacob whether it's you're
making 55 65 75
um
like i know as you go through and do
your budget though and you're and you're
doing your expenses and then you're
getting to this point at baby steps four
five and six
uh and after you do the 15 and you want
to put some in for college and you're
going to pay the house off early right
like it he said he said he could do all
that he's running tight but i thought i
understood you to say jacob tell me if
i'm wrong okay i thought i understood
you to say you ran the investment
calculator and got one number and when
you sat down with smart investor pro
they gave you a different number and
that number that you didn't feel like
you were going to be able to build
wealth based on what the smartvestor pro
told you and you were just pressed by
that is that what you said right
yeah absolutely so when we did the
online calculator
the we're really struggling honestly to
know if we should continue with this
smart investor or if we should look for
someone else i think you should look for
someone else okay okay okay you got a
bad start here whether it's a guy's
fault or your fault i don't know you got
a bad start but the honeymoon was rough
so um yeah so i i you know you got to
have a person handling your money that
you're comfortable with yeah and that
you that you trust and so forth so
here's the thing
the next time this kind of a
conversation comes up go ahead and
challenge it
and go okay what's the difference in
this and when i ran the calculator
because that's you being the owner of
your money and they're there to teach
you not them there to go well you're
only going to get this much money and
you go oh crap well i'm not going to go
over there because that guy's not going
to do it listen there ain't going to do
with the guy anything with you it's what
you put it in
sure and so if you pick good growth
stock mutual funds that get average
annual rates of return and you save 15
of 65 or 70 000 a year from age 27 to
age 67 you're going to have north of 5
million
sure and that's what we're seeing on
your website and that's what my brain
can keep i didn't even use a calculator
and the confusion was just sitting down
with him and hearing he must have been
running a lower rate of return or an
inflation and rejust adjusted rate of
return to be conservative because those
guys always like to under promise and
over deliver but it's not up to them
it's up to you
sure so yeah i would sit down with a
different one and go listen when i run
the numbers out here's what i get and
here's the thing by the way both of you
are wrong and so am i because your life
is not going to unfold linearly
to where you go okay we're going to
project this based on a three percent
cost of living raise per year and we're
always going to give 15 of the new cost
of living and we're projecting that the
house is going to be paid off here and
when it pays off we're going to fully
max out all retirement and that's going
to take us to there there's like 73
variables oh and by the way you got more
raises than that oh by the way
your rich uncle died that you didn't
even know you had oh by the way you sign
up for a stock plan at your company and
somehow get a big bonus that way that
you didn't see coming there's a whole
bunch of stuff going to happen in the
next 20 years you have no idea what it
is and most of it's good
so the numbers are wrong it's just an
idea to keep you moving totally yes and
jacob and anyone else listening i think
that this is a great though
reminder that when you sit down with
someone i mean you know he's 20 27 years
old the first time to probably maybe sit
down with a financial advisor i get it
it can be intimidating like winston i
just went with ours we go every january
just to re-look at everything
and even though i know what i'm doing
for the most part and we know everyone
it's still i mean it still takes me a
hot second to be like okay this like
it's an intimidating thing and when
you're not in this world and you don't
know so yeah so all that to say ask
questions and if you feel like no this i
i'm getting something different here on
this website tell me what's different
here versus there and and don't feel
stupid to ask
questions be the eight-year-old little
boy why
why
why they ask why about everything do you
want to kill them why yeah why don't do
it because it's your money absolutely
i'm glad you called jacob because it is
it's confusing and so hopefully that
gave you some clarity and i think you
were onto something there you get
someone that you get that comfort level
with that you're not intimidated with
whether it's his fault or not i'm not
even blaming him
but you got a rough start there there's
other smart vista pros get one that you
has the heart of a teacher that you can
jive with
and that doesn't take care of you but
teaches you
and that's the whole thing this is the
ramsey
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
one of our favorite things to do is to
take a call from someone and tell us
their debt-free story so they can do
their debt-free scream the thing that's
more favorite is if they're actually
here live in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage which
by the way you can come visit us anytime
you'd like we've got a coffee shop and
the coffee and the homemade cookies are
free there's a bookstore a whole
experience when you come to visit the
ramsey headquarters we'd love to have
you but the only thing even more
favorite than all of that is our own
team members on the debt free stage
yeah
so scott pina and his wife molly are
with us to do their debt-free scream
scott's been with us about a year he
works on the ed solutions team helping
to get high school curriculum and
curriculum in middle schools all across
america and uh welcome man hey thank you
congratulations you guys thank you so
cool so happy to be here well done how
much have you all paid off a hundred and
fifty three thousand dollars wow how
long did that take took 34 months good
for you okay and 12 of those
approximately you have been here right
so two years before you got here two or
two years before you got here and a year
after you got here you're working on
this right so i don't ask your incomes
because you work here and all your all
your compadres are standing around
completely inappropriate but uh tell us
your story what happened
oh man about three years ago we had just
gotten engaged and um we got your book
my parents found you later in their
marriage and kind of learned the hard
way similar to your story um of you and
sharon dave and
so that was one thing that they were
really you know wanted to encourage us
to look into this right as we got
engaged and i think we were just both
really convicted right when we started
reading total money makeover
that we had been blessed with so much
and had just
found the love of our life that we had
been praying for and yet we had no idea
how to handle our finances
and uh we were i remember we were
reading one story about a family with
three children and
taking out a second mortgage and having
two car loans and we just looked at each
other and said that's going to be us
like we gotta get this together
um and just yeah we were totally bought
in right away read the book in two weeks
and i mean it was it was over after that
game on game on we are so you get
married and go we're not right taking
all this baggage into our marriage like
let's let's go what kind of debt was 153
000
101 of it was student loans ouch i know
big sally that's it she's out
i love it give her the eviction notice
that's it and the rest was just
dumb consumer debt we had credit cards
taxes owed family loan our wedding
so some more credit cards
wow
wow okay yeah so
where were you all living when you first
got married
uh we were living in southern california
okay yes and and how do you end up here
for the last 12 months of the journey
we uh spent two years in chicago live
downtown chicago and uh
you know uh coveted was part of a
blessing because everything was shut
down and so we could just tackle our
debt and uh we had nothing else going on
yeah uh and uh yeah so i spent two years
in chicago and then um you know during
the whole journey of of us tackling our
debt we were just
we're like you know why don't we shoot
for this
for our dreams and uh
try to try to make our way down to
nashville and work for uh
we're for an organization that's
obviously just changed our life forever
and you know changed our family tree
we've got a little one now and
and i work in ram's yet and i can't be
more blessed to uh just help that next
person not be another scott pena out
there you know
taking out student loans and consumer
debt so
selling our curriculum is just
life-changing you know because i could
get to give back any way i can yeah way
to go gosh well i feel like it's you
know when you say three years over the
scope of
life it's like oh three years absolutely
we talk about you know just make the
sacrifice and all that but when you're
in the middle of the three years right
when you're in month like nine and ten
and you're like wow and so there were
hard parts i know so what was like what
was the hardest part though of this
journey for you guys take this one baby
um
so we parked our car about a mile away
for for about a year and a half and so i
was definitely checked my in the snow
and everything because we didn't want to
pay for parking at our um
our high rise in chicago yeah in chicago
because we're in the city right so we
parked her car a mile away
every day i'd walk over there and grab
our car just to save and we had one car
one car we never had cable
uh we walked everywhere um
you know even if a train stop i was two
stops away instead of paying two dollars
to take the red line or whatever one of
those lines out there i just walk it
anyways you know anything i can do just
to save uh we walked miles wow we did
i just walked yeah i think the hardest
part for me was just and the most
impactful financially was just doing the
rice and beans um literally for our food
budget you know we lived on 60 a week
for three meals a day for the two of us
and
that was that just really helped us
really helped us reach our goals but was
really difficult really got tired of
some foods
[Laughter]
so we just had to really keep
encouraging each other that this is
temporary yeah but um i mean we came
into this marriage with with a bunch of
debt and it just strengthened us in so
many ways you know all the difficult
conversations we we had it was just it
was just you and i you know and we were
our biggest cheerleaders the whole way
out
um what a way to start it was just i
mean it was a blessing right now we just
we just went after it you know and now
we've got a brand new little boy who was
born three months ago and stuff and so
you know it's just awesome you know very
cool you guys and i love that part
though about the relationship because
there is something to be said that we
live in such like a microwave culture
right like we just want we just want the
results but when you have to walk a
journey and specifically when you're
married and you do it together right
like the what is formed in that
relationship during the time that it's
just it's not easy and it's like that
that
dragging feeling right and thinking of
the impossible and then you cross the
finish line together it's like the
victory is that much more sweet right
it's so sweet
so exciting i love that
i told scott recently that um there were
times in the middle where i
i would think like man i wish we were
one of those couples that had twenty
thousand dollars of debt
you know
and uh you know it just felt like such a
big mountain but on the other side you
know i feel like you know we may not
have been changed in the way that we
have been through the lord's leading if
it hadn't been so big yeah you know
because it really required a lot of us
so i'm you know even though it was
really difficult in retrospect i'm
grateful because i i think if the amount
worth is big we wouldn't have been
changed as much yes that's great
the
transformed
of form
way to go guys so proud of you all right
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
man
communication uh was key i mean we cut
cable so we actually had to have
conversations with each other in this
crazy world of technology and so we
actually had dinners together where we
cooked together we budgeted we saved a
lot of mexi mexi bowls because of rice
and beans and beans rice so
but communication and patience uh
diligence and just just don't give up
you know just never give up because it's
only 34 months it's not that long in the
grand scheme of things and uh
how does it feel now that you're done oh
my gosh i've been teary all day it feels
incredible yeah yeah it feels so very
good
very good who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
each other you know um my in-laws though
they were the ones that introduced us to
uh
total money makeover and we read that
thing so quick it was ridiculous and
then
just after that it was just take off uh
we're done with this
past life also listening in
listening into the show and hearing
other debt-free screams and seeing
people with bigger amounts in ours and
you know different different situations
and other obstacles that was really
encouraging to see other people's
stories and this is a dream come true to
be here today yeah it's awesome well
it's a dream come true to have you way
to go guys very very proud of you we've
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
which you already got but we'll give you
another one well thank you another copy
of total money makeover which you
already got but you can have that too
you can give them both away we'll go
ahead and give your christmas gifts for
next year but
both number one best sellers of course
we're so proud of you guys
congratulations very very very you're
gonna grab the babe we are good yeah
babe in the picture oh my goodness what
is his name this is baby bennett baby
bennett three whole months old
he doesn't even know what's going on
matter of fact he's getting ready to be
scared after this yeah
so you don't want the headphones or
anything
[Laughter]
all right scott and molly and bennett i
love it
153 000 paid off in 34 months and he'll
be calling your high school soon to get
the high school curriculum in so your
teachers answer up out there count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're done
[Applause]
what's the best
i thing it
oh and they screamed anyway yeah i love
it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author three times over we're here to
take your calls
about your life
your money your careers your
relationships it's all here on the
ramsay show ben is with us in newark new
jersey hi ben welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how you guys doing thank you so
much for taking my call i greatly
appreciate it sure what's up
um so
i'm 42 years old
i'd like to just kind of rattle off some
numbers kind of maybe you could help me
get organized and answer one of my
questions
i'm currently debt free
except i do have two investment
properties one's 190 000 that i have
left on it and another one for 160 000.
i have a 120 in
mutual funds 72k in an ira
in my business i have 70k and i have an
emergency fund of 60 000.
so i guess where i'm at right now based
upon my age is i'm wondering if i should
should i
since i have an emergency fund and i
have a good amount of money on the side
keep letting that build for compound
interest
because if maybe somebody a tenant moves
out i have a good emergency fund saved
up
or
should i
be emptying out my mutual fund take my
business uh some of my money into my
business and my emergency fund and pay
off
one of the property so now i have three
paid off properties i don't know if i
mentioned that too i also have two
i have my own
residence has paid off and another
investment property paid off
okay and what are you making i'm just
trying to organize what do you make
uh pretty much between
80 and 120 i
work in the sports field i own a uh
sports training company good for you so
well done you've done a great job
thank you dave i appreciate you've been
my mentor you and everybody you've had
on there has been absolutely amazing to
me my wife loves you guys too and here's
the thing i don't think you're as
disorganized as maybe you feel like
because you were able to just rattle off
your exact numbers sounds pretty
organized to me
so
you know maybe maybe what you want to do
is maybe the word's not disorganized
maybe what you're saying is you want to
reallocate some of this and start
accomplishing some of these goals is
that right
yes i just don't know where to start and
i know you always say pay things off i
just wasn't sure
well you've done a great job i mean
you're sitting in uh baby step six
because your rentals aren't yet paid off
and so what i would do if i were you is
i would sit down and say okay i want to
develop a plan to pay off these rentals
that's job one right now
while putting 15 of your income away
into retirement
now so you've got um
what uh 120 in a mutual fund yeah 120 in
a mutual fund and then you've got
300 000 and some change 350 000 in
rental debt
right
yes sir okay
so like you said if you threw the 120 at
the 160 rental
um
you know and if you can scrape up
another 30 or 40 in the next little
while or use some of your business um
emergency fund but your business does
need an emergency fund it does need
retained earnings
so i really wouldn't drain it all the
way down but if you pulled if you pulled
440 out of it and used that mutual fund
then you only got the 190 left
you might build that business emergency
fund back up a little bit after that and
then i would begin to just say i'm gonna
direct all cash flow at that 190 laser
focused and knock it out
would that be a plan okay
yeah i i guess i was just worried
because i always just hear you know
people talking about you know time in
the market and i figured if i took my
120 out
i well you want to be in the market for
a long term but the reason for being in
the market is have wealth and what we're
trying to do here is clear off debt
so yeah the other option would be to
sell one of the rentals
and i don't know if you want to do that
or not
no
they they're renting
everything's kind of really involved
with them so far well i mean you've
listened to me long enough you know i'm
probably more pro real estate than i am
mutual funds i love both i have a lot of
money in both
but if i'm choosing i'm going to choose
real estate because i'm a real estate
good that's what's going to ask is that
okay so i'm using the 120 towards the
160. i might or might not use the
company emergency fund the thing about
using it is it's going to increase your
cash flow immediately because you got no
debt
on that rental and that rental cash flow
goes through the roof all of a sudden
like what's the payment on the rental
uh
one rental is
12.54 the other one's 1508.
okay so 1254 is going to be freed up day
one if you do this you could write
checks today out of the mutual fund and
out of the business emergency fund and
have 1254 a month cleared up that's 14
for a year
okay it's not the end of the world you
could do it i mean or if you want to
just throw if you're not gonna do that i
throw the 120 on the mutual fund for
sure i'm doing that one
at the 160 and then cash flow that last
40
and then when that and keep your
emergency run in the business if you
want to i don't care none of this is on
fire none of this is gazelle intensity
this is all intentionality not intensity
so it's kind of like we're just going
around the monopoly board
and you know we're just going to collect
some money go around again collect some
money go around again hit free parking
woohoo right you know and um
yeah that so
i'm throwing the 120 at it today i might
throw 40 out of the business emergency
fund depending on how stable you feel
like your business is then the next job
is to rebuild that business emergency
fund followed by every other dollar of
cash you can find after that's done
start throwing at that 190. i'll bet
you're done with that 190 in three years
that's what we're hoping we're actually
expecting our first baby soon oh
kind of like
yeah yeah so i don't know if that would
that change anything no
no i don't change anything
because you're in good shape for the
baby you don't worry about the baby
everything's good
thank you dave it's just listen there's
not a wrong answer here you've done
really smart if you sit right where you
are you're not dumb
all i was doing was trying to tune it up
a notch
okay you've done a great job just go
ahead and go ahead and just sit in that
for a moment
you're sitting there with a lot of money
good job good job so rentals are it's a
big thing i feel like or maybe it's just
the seasonal life i'm in and knowing
people and talking to people but it
feels like getting rental property is
like it's exciting and and people are
doing it more and more is what it feels
real estate's quite the rage right yeah
you're right so
for you being a real estate guy and for
someone listening that has a rental they
have debt on it
you know maybe they don't have a ton of
cash to throw at it all that
you know keeping a rental and paying it
off obviously is the goal but that
between the market you just it's a it
could be either or it's kind of what
you're telling him a decent rental that
you pay decent that you paid a
reasonable price for not makes you more
money
than the stock market will make you
okay including the depreciation schedule
including the cash flow including the
appreciation the increase in value those
are the three rates three places you get
return on rentals it's called an
internal rate of return when you put
them all three together but
it's more hassle yes as you know your
husband winston runs all of our rentals
and you guys have your rentals so it's
their hassle
and mutual funds you just open up the
email and go oh there it is right right
there's no hassle at all they don't have
to do anything that mutual funds don't
ever uh have a dog that pees in the
living room floor you know i mean so
but tenants do and so cat no one told
you about them
oh the ten thousand dollar cat they will
screw up a house okay so yeah stink
and so um
man but over time okay yeah but over
time real estate real estate is going to
make you more money but it costs you
more emotional and time bandwidth it's
more hassle
and i don't want you keeping real estate
under the heading of all real estate's
good because it's not or
all real estate's so good that i can
justify debt to do it no you can't if
you're already there like he is i'm not
gonna make you pan i wouldn't tell you
to panic i can't make you do anything
but i wouldn't tell you to panic and
jump out yeah but i don't want you to
get caught up in this get rich quick
real estate vibe that's running around
out there that says all real estate's
good the renters are going to pay my
payments which writers don't pay
payments you pay payments hopefully you
collect rent
but we'll see you know and so that's
just bs the renter's going to pay it off
if the renter was going to pay it off
the renter would own it okay that's just
bunk
so don't don't fall into all that crap
but if you've got a gotta you can go
slow about getting it paid off so have a
three-year plan a five-year plan to get
them paid off not a 15-year plan yes to
get them paid off get them done get them
done or get them sold
and some of them you own and they're not
even making money
and all they are is a hassle
it's like a bad ugly hobby
sell the crap out of that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today as we answer
your questions about your relationships
your mental health your money and your
careers all right here on the ramsey
show every day triple eight eight two
five five two two five bianca is with us
in boston hi bianca how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so my husband and i are on baby step two
and we've paid off all of our debt
except for my student loan which is the
largest part of our debt i have uh
i was gifted about six thousand dollars
or it was about three thousand at the
time so it's more than doubled in size
an investment account when i graduated
from high school and i'm trying to
figure out if i should take that out or
if it will be too hard in tax
implications to take that out or if i
should just leave it in there
you should take it out and pay off your
debt
okay
how should we plan for paying the tax
off on that at the end what's it
invested in
it's just invested in mutual funds so
it's in a general brokerage account it's
not a retirement where did you get it
you put in where'd you put in the 3000
i was gifted to you
yeah so my my grandparents had gifted it
to me as a high school graduation gift
they put three thousand dollars of cash
in at that time or was it an account
they already had
it was cash that they put in for me at
that time right so your basis in this is
three thousand dollars anything over
three is going to be taxed at a capital
gains rate of 15
and so that's 450 if your gain is if
your total is six thousand so your gains
three times fifteen percent is 450 bucks
okay
so just set aside five hundred dollars
extra in your savings account so when
your tax bill comes a year from now
you'll be ready and use the rest of it
for your debt
okay yeah that's a lot less than we
expected so that's uh
uh hopefully that's
that's not too bad yeah that's going to
be it because you're it's a long term
capital gains you've held it longer than
a year when you receive a gift your
basis in the gift is what the person
paid for it which in this case was three
thousand dollars and so your gain is
anything over the basis
and that is the gain is taxed at fifteen
percent on long-term capital gains i'm
not a tax expert but that is the right
answer you can double you can double
check it with an actual tax expert the
math that you can do in your head dave
ramsey i just can't i still can't i'm
like oh my gosh
what
know i don't know it's just quick math
just fast math we grew up with t9
calculators in my day we had we got we
got a calculator i did see that meme the
other day which was really funny
which one it was like the uh
take this 90s teacher the teacher
standing up going
someday you're going to be in a
situation where you don't have a
calculator you're like taking a test and
he's like holding his iphone going no
yeah
i'm not i'll never be in a situation
where there's not a calculator there's
always a calculator i've never been in a
situation where there's not a camera or
a flashlight i've got them all right
here at all times
that's so true it's so true i'm crawling
around in the parking garage last night
with the flashlight looking for your
mother's iphone who had dropped hers out
of the car in the parking garage so yeah
you've always got a flashlight you know
it's just you know you've hit your
system it's like it's like macgyver it's
like macgyver you know you've got your
little trick your little swiss pocket
knot swiss army knife right here all
built in it's so off subject but there
has to be something
true about like the neurological part of
your brain when you grew up having to do
math in your head you know what it is
it's actually flex that muscle doing the
show for 30 years okay so i can't i
can't do real math i can do big math
yeah round numbers yeah i can do round
numbers really really fast so you'll
hear me round stuff
and sure and hit close sure okay but um
and i used to run the calculator in the
old days i'd have it sitting here yeah
when i first started when i first
started the show but i got to where i
just got impatient with that and you
could just it but it's a muscle you just
learn to do it it's like memory yeah
you'll be able to do it in a couple
minutes i know i know
i don't know i feel like i have to like
right now fifteen percent okay fifteen
three thousand point one maybe
bumping up a little bit there you go
there you go that's not bad or as we're
talking about we'll get to a call james
james like y'all shut up uh or dave math
dave math is like
dave's like you're gonna have a billion
dollars at age 65.
i'm like i don't know if that's right
that's called dave math
oh dave matthews exaggeration math and
you have dave math dave math
it's funny funny
all right
let's just keep moving here craig is in
pittsburgh hey craig how are you
hello there hey both of you thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
so my wife and i find you guys about two
years ago i like to think god led me to
you but um we're currently on baby step
four five and six we're got a daughter
in college we're cash flowing we have a
son who's a sophomore we're saving
college for we're investing in
retirement at 15. good for you and were
you we're still trying to put actually
the mortgage every month good so
listening to the show for a couple years
my thought my my question is you know
when people are in baby step 3c saving
for a down payment on a house we have
325 000 in our retirement accounts right
now we still got a waste for retirement
about 15 years or so so if i invest
nothing based on your role of seven
i'm figuring that grows to about 1.3
million in 14 years
so would it be worthwhile pausing
investment for a couple years because
we're putting so much cash into college
uh to help pay down our mortgage which
is at about 175.
we don't teach people to do that and the
reason we don't is
that you're going let me just tell you
okay you're going to be fine
if you don't use our system
and you use that system
but that's not what we teach okay the
reason we teach people not to do that is
the let's say you do that for five years
that's five years of money that you
couldn't keep away from the government
okay you can never go back in retro and
do i roth iras for the last five years
you can only do them in the year in the
year that you're allowed to do them you
cannot go back retro and fill your 401k
you can only fill it out of your payroll
right then that month that year and so
those years that you were going to park
that money and it was going to be
growing tax-free and roth
are gone forever uh and
and here's the other thing if you run
the numbers out it doesn't change
the payoff date on the house that much
okay let's let's say the kids are done
with let's for simplification let's run
a little math let's say the kids are
done with school
okay yeah now what's your household
income
or about 180.
okay so let's call it uh twenty eight
thousand dollars a year is thirty
percent right
right that's what we're doing so twenty
eight thousand dollars a year is thirty
percent so if we quit doing i mean if we
quit this is fifteen percent i'm sorry
uh so uh if we quit doing that it gains
us 28 000 towards 175. but you make 180.
the way you get the house paid off is
not the 28. it's get the kids out of
school and then tighten the budget and
hit the house with the rest of it the 30
000 towards 175 is not going to be your
secret pill it's not enough
it doesn't change them it changes your
pa house payoff date by
maybe two years or something like that
and you miss the market when you pause
the retirement and you miss all those
that's sheltered income yeah so
you're changing the numbers by only
about two years
and that's usually the way it works out
by the way
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
money is one of the biggest sources of
stress for married couples
everyone's dealt with it including
sharon and i will be married 40 years
this summer
and charinois says we've had 33 good
years of marriage
[Laughter]
hey it's normal man seven left i'm
kidding
it's not not the last seven but yeah
there's you just spattered throughout
the 40. but the uh hey this is uh
when we figured out that this money
thing was a big deal
we set out to learn the right way of
managing money and it changed our
marriage so this valentine's day instead
of an ordinary
date night put an end to money stress in
your marriage or bless a couple who's
planning to tie the knot our valentine's
day sale includes all kinds of gifts
that'll help you strengthen your
marriage and there's much as 83 off the
brand new questions for humans
conversation cards for couples
now i got to tell you this little box of
conversation cards looks like playing
cards and you just got a question you
asked and spurs conversation has sold
faster than just about anything we have
ever put in our bookstore you people
have gone nuts over this thank you we
appreciate it john deloney thanks you we
appreciate it you get 55 conversation
starters that'll help you connect with
your spouse laugh together share some
truly meaningful quality time
you can gift our popular bundle the
wedding pack for newlyweds engaged
couples and these aren't your ordinary
valentine's day gifts go to our online
store at ramsey solutions shop the
valentine's day sale to get up to 83 off
before it ends and rachel and john are
doing the money and marriage live stream
on friday night i know just a few what i
guess tomorrow night tomorrow night yes
for those of you listening live yeah
before the scene live yep um friday
night the 11th and uh it's gonna be a
couple hours long yeah so um about hour
and a half hour and a half two hours and
it's gonna be great we're gonna teach on
we're gonna talk through five different
conversations to have
with you and your spouse need to have so
it's everything from
goals to fear to trust to asking for
what you need
intimacy all of it so it's going to be
it's great it's always fun too great for
20 bucks
yeah just go to ramses.com get the
tickets
code i guess that's what it would be
but join us yeah it's going to be a
really it's going to be a fun night and
i think
you know there's so much content out
there these days right like you're just
bombarded
um so just like i don't know trick your
spouse say you're gonna watch
yellowstone and then
boom
here we are you've already caught up on
a tv maybe maybe you've already seen the
season ending and so oh okay well 1783
yeah but no it's a great it's always a
fun event so yeah join us yeah check
that out and those of you that are
ramsey plus members already it's free to
watch it so make sure you plan on tuning
in don't miss that as well all right
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five our question of the day
comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping new promos all the time it's a
great american company
great blinds and window coverings for
your house use the promo code ramsey and
you'll get a great deal
today's question comes from michael in
wisconsin
my wife and i retired and we have a few
goals that we'd like to accomplish we'd
like to remodel our home and buy an rv
for travel we have a substantial
retirement investments nearing a seven
figure sum i would like to use our home
equity to finance the remodel
the travel trailer and newer truck
uh we would then increase the
withdrawals from our investments to pay
off the heloc what do you think about
this plan oh michael not a great plan
um
no i mean you're going to go backwards
you guys are in retirement got a million
dollars just pay for the stuff
cash out something fix your house and
buy a truck dude that's why you did this
i'm going dead
no
the heloc
no
man it's hard to get away from debt in
this culture it is so freaking insidious
it's just everywhere crammed down your
throat all
that and what's interesting is because
i'm assuming the reason not to put the
assumptions on michael
but it's the feeling of okay i could
just take money i don't have to take a
big chunk out
and pay for all this at once because
that feels scary so i'm going to just do
a little bit at a time
but what's not factored in is that
little bit of a time you're adding risk
onto your life when you owe
money on stuff and specifically stuff
that's going down in value like yeah i
just
yeah no michael the borrower's slave to
the lender you've got almost a million
dollars
you know you said that's what you said
nearing a seven figure sum
so buy you a truck buy you a trailer
remodel your house
or don't
but pay for it if you're gonna do it
if you're too cheap to do it
and pay cash for it then don't use a
heloc and make it feel like you didn't
really do it mm-hmm it's a there's a
form of financial denial in things like
that didn't really spend the money when
you borrow it
brianna is with us brianna is in salt
lake city hey brianna what's up
hi uh how are you guys doing today great
how are you
doing well i'm i just have a question so
i i currently work in a hospital
part-time
and i also am starting up well it's a
business that i've had for the last two
years which unfortunately when i first
started it it was two weeks right before
the pandemic had started
and
um but this year i'm finally going to be
able to have a consistent schedule
because my husband's schedule changed
um and i'm also going to school to get
into nursing school and on top of all
that i'm a mom of five from kids from
ages eight to one well you're bored so
i know right there's not much to do here
so um anybody ever tell you you're
trying to do too much at once
uh my husband actually this morning just
because he hasn't seen you in a while
uh she he sees me but he doesn't
have me there
when he sees me
yeah
it's been
i'm one of those i'm trying to do what i
can for our family but also trying to
find balance and everything and i
there's a lot of fear behind
the decisions i'm trying to decide on
and
um
like going to school i'm
trying to get into nursing school um
so i work as a tech
on a labor and delivery unit and
my business that i actually do is i do
uh permanent cosmetics
um okay so 10 years from today what is
it you want to be doing permanent
cosmetics nursing
uh so
yeah i can
the ultimate goal is to
have
the my nursing where i can incorporate
like botox and lip fillers like cosmetic
stuff into my
permanent uh makeup that i do right now
um
and you have to have a nursing degree
for that
i know there's different licenses you
have to have but i didn't know it
specifically
yeah yeah and so but even just like my
microblading that's what it specifically
i do with permanent makeup i um
i make i can make a decent amount of
money monthly definitely way more than
what i make working part-time at the
hospital
um
right now
but the fear is is like
letting go of that
secure pay how much does your husband
make
uh so my husband makes
56 000 a year what are you making at the
permanent makeup thing
um
if i do it consistently and
work my butt off
i could be making around 3 500 to 4 500
a month okay
all right
and what do you make at the labor and
delivery
uh
21 000
quit
yeah
and don't go to nursing school right now
and grow yeah grow your business and
grow your kids
grow your business and grow your kids
if you need a different license if you
need to add nursing later
five years from now to continue to
mature your business you may just hire a
nurse or you may
hire someone that is licensed to do that
stuff uh yeah briana i got my
appointment i got my appointment march
one and it ain't cheap it ain't cheap so
brianna
kill it girl i
really quit doing the 21 000. i pay
attention to my kids and i grow my
business
and love your husband
you're going to enjoy your life better
and i wouldn't go to nursing school
until you had to and i probably wouldn't
ever go i'd just hire a nurse
or hire a medical whatever that you need
to do to be legal in your state to do
whatever it is the flip you do this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author new york times
multiple times my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on that
debt-free stage jimmy and jade are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
doing welcome where do you guys live
we live in magador ohio which is near
akron okay yeah right good cool good to
have you guys welcome to nashville and
how much debt have you paid off 45 000.
whoo how long did that take about three
years good for you and your range of
income during that time 50 to 100 000.
good for you man you guys have been
getting it how old are you guys
uh i'm 22 and i'm 25. oh my goodness
that's awesome y'all that's awesome so
you started this when you were 19.
pretty much yeah how long you all been
married
uh nine months
old
okay so you started as singles yep
combined and finished yep correct very
good cool all right so what kind of debt
was this
about 25 000 was my student loans and
the rest were car loans okay so each of
you had a car loan yeah and then you had
the student loans i did yes okay cool
very cool you guys started young on this
yes so what's the story are you
financial peace babies mom and dad were
doing this stuff or what
um i was introduced to it in high school
but i didn't really uh take it the high
school curriculum
well we did the envelope system yeah
okay but i didn't apply it i went to
college took out a bunch of loans and uh
just decided when we were getting ready
to get married i didn't want to carry
that into our marriage so i want to take
responsibility for it and get it done
yeah yep all right and and so you look
at the fiance
and uh jimmy says what
uh yeah i don't really want your uh
alone so you know let's get them going
you but i don't want challenge yes i
don't like sally
yeah
i like you don't like her yeah
that's good
that's awesome you're ugly your ugly
roommate has got to go yeah yeah
that's awesome you guys okay so
i think this is always so unique because
you get people on the stage from all
different
you know walks of life stages of life
all of this but you guys are on the
younger side for sure and you're like
starting out your lives you're starting
out your marriage like this so what was
the first nine months of marriage like
having a goal because i mean the way you
guys are unified now people want that
have been married 30 years and you guys
are doing this i mean from beat the
beginning which is awesome so so what
was it like working together for those
nine months
i think it was pretty it wasn't i mean
it was hard but it wasn't you know we
made it easy on each other you know what
i mean
uh just simple stuff like not eating out
for lunch with the guys and you know
just following the steps yeah that she
told me so
he learned early
what do you guys do for a living i'm an
accountant
i worked heavy construction for a while
now i'm in school so what are you
studying uh auto tech good for you and
paying cash as you go obviously yep yep
yeah and how much did you owe on your
card jimmy i think it was about 12 000
okay so you had the bigger car loan
yeah yeah okay all right cool good for
you guys
thanks very very well done all right who
are your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you once you start doing this
you start telling us to people and your
family that looks at you and goes you've
lost your mind and joined a cult
or they go this is the smartest thing
you've ever done i wish i'd done it when
i was your age yeah yeah right
definitely our family and my brother
actually works here so he motivated us
who's your brother who's your brother
jaren smith oh my gosh
didn't make that connection that's
awesome yeah so he's given us all the
material helping us through the steps so
he definitely challenged us to stay on
it oh yeah he can ship you cases of the
kool-aid
very cool who else was cheering you on
our parents okay good good so they
believed in common sense too then they
did yeah they definitely instilled that
at a young age that
so what a lot of your friends think
because you guys are at the prime age i
feel like when you know you're paying
off your debt and hey my perception of
the 22 year old age group is exactly i
got a question
it's exactly the i was going to
piggyback on that question pick it back
the same question come on jump on ride
here okay go so
my perception is that there's no middle
ground that people you guys age are
either doing this stuff or they
completely are on the other side and
they think you're nuts am i wrong no no
you're right correct okay
so what are your friends so what are
your friends saying
one or the other right well yeah a lot
of my friends some went to college
straight out of high school and some
just went to work you know and
uh i think
you know waiting
to figure out what you really want to do
instead of taking out massive loans and
going to a ginormous college really
really helped you know that set up a lot
of my friends and guys i hung around
with in a bad way you know
so what it so you guys through this
process though where you know some of
your friends are just paying probably
minimum payments or maybe nothing right
now because there's nothing going on
right uh so you know what are they what
do they think do they think golly that
wasn't that's impossible that you guys
did that do they are they encouraging
with it like what i'm just curious their
take on everything
i think it's just
a lot of them are just have nice cars
buying homes and we're kind of doing the
opposite you know we're saving for a
down payment we're not jumping into
those things so we are a little bit
outside of the norm but yeah yeah that's
awesome very cool way to go guys thanks
you guys are amazing what a power couple
man
you're gonna be killing it i'm just so
proud of you thank you very very neat
well i i get to uh on this stage and in
a lot of other settings as well run into
a ton of
22 and 25 and 26 year olds we've got a
bazillion that work here from 25 to 30
out of our 1200 people here there's a
the average age is under 30. so i get to
hang out with very very smart and very
driven and very crusade mission-minded
young people all day long so it's just
given me great hope for the future of
our culture and our nation because you
do see all the morons out there within
any generation yeah every generation's
got a percentage of absolute morons yeah
and so uh yours included but you're but
sometimes the
millennials were the first ones to get a
bad day we can get a bad rap but a bad
rap about being entitled or arrogant and
i find you know i find the same thing
with millennials i think there's no
middle ground they're either awesome or
they suck you know i mean it's just
incredible so you guys are you guys are
on the awesome awesome bucket list i'm
so proud of you guys
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you yes sir that's the next chapter
in your story for sure number one
bestseller how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too can
you imagine how rich they're going to be
at 22 he starts this well i was about to
say that i mean it's like people are
listening right now and they're like god
what if i had done that at 22. you know
so you guys are awesome i mean you
really are and the fact that you
sacrificed at this time in life and not
saying that the sacrifice wasn't
difficult for you guys by any means but
you know once you have kids and you're
living life and you're used to a certain
living and you gotta really pull back
like but you guys are like it was
perfect like it was perfect where you
guys are when you started you started
together married all of it finished it i
mean it's just awesome i think it's the
future is unbelievably bright and that's
what's amazing we say you're changing
your family tree yeah and there's no
stopping that for you guys i mean the
math is just going to explode in every
which way to your direction so congrats
thank you for your hard work you paid
off early and i'm so happy for you thank
you when their parents are jumping up
and down because they know they'll never
live in their basement
oh way to go guys and a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away to
one of your doubting friends
we'll disrupt their lives a little bit
that's one of our goals so good for you
guys
all right it's jimmy and jade very
impressive akron ohio 45 000 paid off in
three years started as two singles and
then finished as a married couple making
fifty to a hundred thousand count it
down let's hear a debt free screen yeah
one three two two
start with again start over
[Applause]
i love it
that
is awesome can you imagine
i i can't do the math it's too far out
oh you can't so from do something
that would be fun from 22 to 62
you invest 15 000 a year they make a
hundred thousand dollars and they never
get a raise
that's uh i can tell you that it is
north of 10 million dollars okay
it's probably north of 20 million but
i'm not positive about that i'm positive
it's north of 10. but if you if they
just invest 15 of their income if that's
all they ever do and they never get a
raise which those two are going to get
raises they're going to double their
income sure yeah they're going to be and
so how wealthy they're going to be i
mean we're looking at not just
millionaires but deca millionaires if
and they really don't even have to
strain to do it yeah that's right that's
right they're not living in a cave
collecting length they're just going to
be steadily investing intentionally
while they live their lives they'll be
baby steps millionaires in no time and
then they'll move on from there
very very important very cool very
inspiring this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your work your mental
health your relationships your money
it's what we do at ramsey thank you for
joining us kevin is with us in columbia
south carolina hi kevin welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave rachel uh thank you so much for
taking my call
i'll give you a little backstory here 20
years ago i'm a 40 year old divorce
father raising 18 year old with 25 grand
in my retirement 40 000 in debt
i got focused didn't know about you
but i came out and i'm sitting on about
1.9 million right now with investments
in retirement and way to go
thank you thank you thank you
uh i put money away that's just uh
mutual funds in your 401k
mutual funds 401k i did some some
trading on some a couple of etfs and and
just uh below below the means um
so just uh you know i got gazelle
intense as you say but if i hunted it
down and i killed it
yeah you're amazing man well done i'm
proud of you just just laser focused and
uh and that's part of the issue that i'm
facing right now is that um
i'm about the smart mister pro matter of
fact just got off the phone with a
little while ago are going to go on
board with them
but i've driven this this boat or this
bus for so long on my own i'm just
having trouble
uh
with the perception that i'm letting go
of things and need to kind of get some
advice from you or some wisdom how to
walk through that process
well um
the smartvestor pro if they're doing
their job properly shouldn't be asking
you to let go of it
they should be helping you they should
be helping you be a gps while you drive
it yeah
yeah and this this this this individual
that we've met with he's
he's answered all the right questions um
and i feel very comfortable but there's
just a part of me on the inside that
says
you know you've done this on your own
for so long well i do it on my own my
smartbuster pro just gives me some ideas
okay and then i you know we talk about
it and then he goes and does the one
that i like
so i'm still driving
okay he's just my
gps gotcha i might i might be a little
bit more efficient because in the
multitude of counsel there's safety
because i'm learning things from him
that i might not have known on my own or
maybe i've got a little better timing on
something or maybe i don't miss a tax
thing that i could have done and i
almost screwed it up and just about
missed the deadline and he keeps me from
doing that so it's fine tuning and
direction and advice but we're not
handing over the steering wheel
okay okay that's how i look at it
does that feel different than what you
thought
no i it does it's just that i've driven
the bus for so long that it's just you
know i feel like it's uh i've always had
control and to be honest we reached out
to them because i'm concerned going into
the next five to seven years into
retirement that uh maybe i don't have
myself in the best position for
retirement or mandatory uh minimal
withdrawals yeah but the point is he can
give you the nuances of that stuff and
you can talk through options
and um you know he may just give you one
or two ideas that are different and you
can look at them and decide to do them
or not do them
but um what i always do is i'll call up
my guy and just go hey listen i'm gonna
put x number of dollars over here i'm
gonna park it over there for about four
years give me some ideas of what you
think we ought to do and he'll bring
them up and i've pulled up a few on my
own and i'll compare them and we'll talk
it through we'll kind of argue it out
like two friends arguing that over a cup
of coffee right and then
but it's my money
i get to decide so i mean rachel you and
winston have a smart investor pro talk
about how to do it i mean it's all of
that and actually kevin i was in a
content meeting right before i came on
the show and uh one of the guys on our
team we were talking about smart
investors and and investing
professionals and doing kind of a show
specifically on that
and he was like yeah the thing i love
about smart fest was exactly what you
said dave was so funny he said i
literally have his num his his cell
phone number so i'll text him and be
like hey my wife and i were thinking
about buying this house and you know and
that you just talk back and forth so
it's just having another person in your
corner it's just like having a team but
it's not like you're um yeah they're
that they're completely taking over but
i get the i can see the feeling that
kevin if you're if you've been pushing
all the buttons this long
to allow someone else to do that it's a
little bit of an extension of you so
that extension can feel a little odd at
first you've been the lone ranger but
here comes tonto to help yeah but so i
think that sure i think there's probably
a natural
strangeness to the change which would
make sense but when you kind of just
delegate it um
for them to push the buttons you still
have the say in it
there's that and then kevin too like you
said i'm like there is there is
something to be said that these people
eat live and breathe this world so
things that you may not even be thinking
about they may be able to just to bring
up and you know like it's it's just
having that um that extra mind
in this in this game with you yeah
winston was telling me about a move that
drew suggested you're your elp the other
day that i thought was just brilliant i
hadn't even thought of it
in your situation it was just he added a
it was about a fifty thousand dollar tax
savings oh yeah on one little move yeah
it was pretty substantial yeah and um
but i didn't even think about it and i
know it and winston knew it yeah but we
just hadn't and he just brought it to
the table so this is you don't ever want
to hear any time kevin you hear people
say stuff like uh my guy told me i
couldn't buy a car
my guy told me i couldn't remodel the
kitchen well your guy is freaking
confused
okay he's not the guy you're the guy
you know so when people say stuff like
that i just cringe because that means
they're getting ready to lose their
money and they won't even know why
you know
and so your guy doesn't tell you
anything you tell your guy what's going
to happen you see the difference okay
yeah absolutely and so it is it is um
it's a little bit invasive in that
there's people kind of going through
your underwear drawer a little bit you
know but but uh but they also can help
you make better decisions you know
overall but again the decision always
rests on you do i turn left do i turn
right i'm still driving the bus and as
long as you keep that control we never
suggest you get rid of that
anytime someone turns over their money
um they're going to be disappointed i
wouldn't as an investment professional
today within fiduciary world out there i
wouldn't take on a client that wouldn't
participate
because i think they're always going to
be mad because you're never going to
live up to their expectations yeah
because they're always going to read
something or hear something somewhere
that you weren't able to do or didn't do
right right and so if you take over
their money and babysit i think you're
setting yourself up for a problem
but if they're in there participating
with you then they made the decision
it's like you know when i get sharon
involved on all major decisions uh she
and i make all major decisions together
and that means she can't say i told you
so if it goes bad
because she had her chance she was in it
she was in the deal you know it's
helpful it's helpful uh fred's with us
in cleveland hi fred how are you
hi dave thanks for everything you and
rachel do um
my wife and i are recently retired we
are in the giving generously stage cool
our smart investor pro has put us in a
good position
we've got about a three million dollar
of assets i'm so proud of you i
thank you i'm proud of my wife she's
talking i'm a little bit i'm a little
bit short on time and i don't want to
mess you up ask your question real quick
okay we've got about a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars we're looking to
give to our children and spouses
or possibly use the whole amount to pay
off our son-in-law's debt
looking for pros and cons
uh well i mean if you
give it all to one kid
what are you gonna do with other kids
well that's one of the questions that's
a con
we come to we come to an agreement and
say hey
when we finally pass away and the estate
gets uh it gets distributed you get that
much less
well that'd be okay if everybody else is
if everybody's got that if we all talk
about that at the kitchen table one
night and everybody's cool with it by
the way our family would be cool with
that
our kids would look at us and go yeah
that's cool
uh because it doesn't affect that it
doesn't affect them but
yeah you got to get everybody's buy-in
you got to get everybody's buy-in and
everybody that way how many kids fred
how many
we have three kids right three spouses
okay yeah
yeah i mean and you know the gift tax
limitations right
yep okay and so how you can move that
money around and i mean the easy fare
thing is just obviously a third right
everyone gets a three and then the
son-in-law that has the debt hopefully
puts a lot of it towards it and ends up
paying it off
but
yeah
it's it's whatever you can afford to do
but you got three million dollars you
could give that much to everybody
and still be okay exactly
so that's another that's a fourth option
that we hadn't talked about but what if
you're going to do something that's
unequal and the rest of it's going to
come out of the estate just have a
meeting and have everybody be on board
that's all i ask
and i think they will be i got a sense
from your spirit that your kids probably
have that same spirit
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author multiple times
is my daughter and my co-host today
we're taking your calls about your
relationships your mental health your
work career and your money it's a free
call and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five michael is with us
michael's in chicago hey michael welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave hi rachel thanks for having me
on sure i had a quick question for you
um
i'm a little older
not terribly old but uh
my kids are uh freshman in high school
and approaching high school age um just
about to finish baby step two it's been
a pretty long grind for about the past
two years and curious on what you think
about home equity line of credit uh if i
keep that in baby step two or if i move
it to four or five and six
uh how much is it um
it's about eighty five thousand dollars
what's your household income
uh around two fifty i would keep it in
two
okay because that you know you can move
it you can move it to six if you move it
to six if you want to but i just
refinance your house if you're going to
okay i think that's what we're gonna do
yeah here's why okay the rule of thumb
we use is if it's less than half your
annual income
we leave it in two
okay and yours is it's not a bunch less
but it's less
and uh yeah you know so it's not unusual
for somebody maybe to call and say in
your situation they got a 20 000 home
equity line well you treat that like a
credit card debt you knock it out right
but in your case i see what you're doing
you're coming to the end of your debt
snowball and you're like yeah i need to
get to work on these kids college i make
a good i make a good income
uh what's your interest rate on your
first mortgage
uh four yeah and you refinance the whole
puppy and you'll be better off anyway
yeah that's what i think just want to
get your confirmation yeah what do you
think rachel
yeah absolutely well and especially
the age of your kids and where you guys
are your stage of life i'm like
i think yeah rolling into the mortgage i
think is
yeah we're behind on you know baby step
four and the college stuff so i think i
need to start prioritizing that as well
yeah and a 15-year fix though no more
yeah yeah
okay hey have at it brother good job
good question
adam is with us adam is in denver hey
adam what's up
hey dave how's it going good man how can
we help
well i just wanted to see what your
opinion was
on this i have fifty thousand dollars in
debt um credit cards and a car
um but i am getting married in august
and we also have um trying to move out
of our parents as we're getting married
or i guess before
um
i don't know if i should focus on the
wedding or uh debt paying off debt in
the wedding
um i want to see what you your thoughts
were
uh it's a lot adam that you got going on
i mean uh definitely
yeah definitely the debt i mean the debt
in the wedding is what i would focus on
and when you have debt though your
wedding is not going to be
huge and glamorous are you guys paying
for it
well
no yeah we're gonna try to do it in cash
we're gonna we're gonna save up for it
our budget is around 3 000 for it and i
think we can make it but that will be
not paying off there
how much do you make
a year uh well i currently got a new
reworked uh new job this year and it's
35 so it's supposed to be a year
um and then she also works uh making
around 20 a year
what does she do
she works at a store at a mall
okay how old are you guys
i'm 26 and she's 21.
okay all right good
all right so you have a fifty five
thousand dollar income you need three
thousand dollars for a wedding and fifty
thousand dollars to get debt free and
you need to move out of the house right
yeah pretty much okay are you talking
about moving are you talking about
moving out you're talking about moving
out of your parents house after august
correct
well before that you know i have a roof
for her to live in and
i mean i think that would be ideal to to
be in our own places after we get
married instead of um yeah but i mean
you can do that in august
yes i guess that's not right after the
wedding yeah yeah um well or the week
before or whatever i mean
so what i would tell you is this moving
into the place shouldn't be that
expensive you are going to take on rent
and it's going to reduce your
ability to pay off debt at that point so
first goal is save three thousand
dollars for the wedding and lay out a
detailed budget of exactly what you're
gonna do with the three thousand dollars
and exactly what the wedding's going to
be and i did not like the language you
used around the wedding you said we are
going to try to pay cash no honey you're
gonna pay cash
no changes no changes i don't want to
hear about anything
okay whatever you save up for the
wedding you can use on the way if you
want to make it five thousand that's
fine with me but you do that first and
you lay out a detailed plan this is how
much the photographer's gonna be this is
what we're spending on the reception
this is how much the dress is this is
how much the uh location is that's what
we're paying the preacher
okay
okay every dollar every it's a project
you're managing a project okay now once
you've got that project detailed out and
you've got that funded then your next
goal is to save up a little bit of money
to make the move out you're going to
need some deposits some first month's
rent some utility deposits and a few
other things you're going to need
another three or four thousand dollars
if you do those two things by august you
probably did a pretty good job yeah
okay and adam and i would encourage her
that right now in this job market you
can make a lot of money
not i mean i know she's working at the
mall but i'm like there are i mean i'm
hearing
25 her job sucks yeah like 25 to drive a
shuttle at the nashville airport i saw a
sign i was like oh my god 25 bucks an
hour i was like that's so much money so
i mean like there are other options so i
really would push her because i think
she could even get close to doubling her
income by just not only just working
more but a totally different line of
work i'm like go go do an admin role or
be a receptionist somewhere you know i
mean fine find something that brings in
more money because that's just gonna liv
give you guys way more margin
in this discussion as well
so what i'm saying is if you have ten
thousand dollars say between now and
august i think you did a pretty good job
and uh some of that's for the wedding
and some of that's for getting into the
new apartment and then as soon as you
get married and get in the new apartment
then the two of you do everything you
can to ratchet your incomes up you do
everything you work extra you take extra
jobs side hustles whatever you want to
call them and you attack this debt with
a vengeance the two of you how much do
you owe on your car
yeah
um i believe it's down to 14 grand we
got it for
20. we've been paying for it for a while
now
we're almost there
we aren't anywhere you are
she her name's not on the car okay
well it's hers i guess and she's helping
me out paying it but you're right i
should be the one it's her car and she's
helping you out paying it
are you driving it right
no she is i i got it for her under my
name because i had one but i got in a
car accident and so i just got me a
beater
and then later on her so this this is
your car and your girlfriend's driving
your car beyonce
yeah right okay well let's just treat
this right i mean let's keep it let's
keep the stuff straight it's not hours
until we're married because there is no
us until we're married financially or
legally so we got to get that straight
but yeah go ahead yeah let's get in
attack mode and knock those two things
out and then knock the dead out after
you get married yes you need to move out
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so let me ask you a question when you
think of a millionaire
what kind of job do you picture them
having maybe they're an nfl star or a
high-powered executive in the corner
office
well here's the thing only 15 of
millionaires only have
jobs like vp or ceo
executive jobs the reality is the top
five careers for millionaires in america
are number one engineer number two
accountant number three teacher number
four manager which would include ceo or
vp and attorney
and that's just one of the many
surprising things our team found when we
conducted the largest study of
millionaires ever done
in north america huge study airtight
research
they talked to 10 000 millionaires to
find out who they really are and how
they really achieved that goal the study
also made it clear that one way to
become a millionaire you've got to
invest steadily wisely consistently and
a big part of that is getting good
investing advice 78 percent of the
millionaires use an investing pro
you need to work with an investing pro
who can help you walk with you and teach
you about the options that are right for
you you drive the bus but they are the
gps they show you where to turn
my team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
we call them smart buster pros to get in
touch with the smartvestor pro in your
area go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and start building wealth
today ramsey solutions dot com slash
smart vester rachel is with us in new
jersey hey rachel welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so
i'm struggling a little bit right now
with trying to figure out how to do a
budget
right now um my husband and i are both
on board that we want to be debt free
but every time i bring up like dave
ramsey or financial peace it's kind of
like
your name is the curse word in our house
a little bit
um
and so my husband is saying you know yes
we'll we'll do a budget but i don't want
any part of it just tell me what the
budget is and then i'll do it and when i
try and figure it out i'm just so
overwhelmed with
trying to figure out what we have and
what money is going where so i just need
a little bit of advice on how to tackle
it head-on and not be so overwhelmed and
get us both on the same page
yeah it's a great question rachel
because
i think your circumstance is very normal
and i think naturally in any
relational dynamic there's going to be
the one that's wanting it more than the
other i think that kind of just happens
right there's one that thrives more in
it than the other
but both working together and being on
the same page can look a lot of
different ways so
um there's a part of me that could see
this going that yes you are overwhelmed
but figuring out the numbers going back
to last month's uh to your checking
account pulling stuff getting all that
yeah it's gonna take work and it's a lot
like i totally i understand that um
but the part that i'm like oh about is
that he's
it's not that he's saying hey
once you do it then i'll get on board
because he's not even wanting to help in
any level the process of wanting to help
you
and that's where a little bit of the red
flag goes up for me we're like man i
wish he
stepped in a little bit more on the
logistical side because you're having
you're having trouble with it right um
so i think going to him
and expressing have you told him like
have you said out loud
i am struggling with this i i need
someone else to walk with me and help me
with this
yes and what's frustrating is i'll say
hey tonight can we set aside time to
figure out a budget and he'll say yes
and then we never end up being able to
do it or i'll ask him like all right how
much money do you think we're gonna need
for this this month and every month is i
i don't know i can't predict an entire
month of what i'm gonna need
and just tell me what the allowance is
and then i'll spend it like i'm not
gonna fight you on it but i just feel
like i've i can't figure it out on my
own no absolutely and then and that
conversation
it's like you being his mom and telling
him right what he can do versus you guys
being a team so i yeah for him for him i
want to know
what is it that makes him so reluctant
what is it that he
is he distracted is there other things
going on is he stressed like what's
going on
i think a big part of it is he didn't
have to do any of this growing up like
he never knew how to pay bills and his
mom did do everything for him so
trying to do a budget or anything
financial just gets him so overwhelmed
where he just shuts down
and then doesn't want any part of it and
he's just like oh whatever tell me tell
me what to do and i'll do it
but he's never had to have the
responsibility of doing it on his own
how old are you guys
uh 28 and 29. how long have you been
married
about three years okay
all right
well i mean um
what what is his uh reaction why is his
reaction negative to uh to uh ramsay
things because you've used it as a
weapon
i don't even know if it's been a weapon
i think it's just
it just represents something he didn't
want fool with
right
okay all right
well i think you separate the ramsey
stuff out from it completely from the
discussion completely because it's a
marriage breakdown
you need your man to be a man
yeah
and by that i mean he needs to be an
equal partner where both of you are
carrying the weight together not he
needs to come in and save the day or not
he needs to do everything and you just
sit beside sit to the side and drink
mint juleps that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about we have two
grown adults that both have intellect
and we're both carrying the weight and
we're both making decisions together
about our future i don't want to be your
mommy and tell you what to do i want a
man
that will sit beside me
and we make decisions for the future
together so bubba man up
that's really what this comes down to
and if he if he can't get that message
in some way or another gentle or blunt
um
i need you as my man to sit with me and
help me do this and you just tossing it
over and you tossing it aside makes me
feel like you're tossing me aside
that's a phrase you could use that's not
threatening him or calling him out but i
need you to be
the man here i can't deal with you being
a little boy
and it's that too rachel that you know
the budget for me always represents
other things right so for you wanting to
do a budget it's because
and i don't know what your why is but is
it because like you know there's a level
of fear that i just need to make sure
like everything's gonna be taken care of
that everything's okay
um a level of of that you feel out of
control with money and it's like i have
i just i wanna control like there's a
why behind you wanting to budget and
become debt free and all of these things
and expressing that why right because
it's not really
yes the budget is the example but what's
hurtful in the situation is that you
guys aren't a team and he's not hearing
you and coming to the table so that's
the issue right
to walk through and it's a hard one
because that that opens up it's a
marital issue at that point it's not a
budget issue and
and that's what let me give you an
example okay let's break do you all have
children
we do we have two children does he do
the same thing with the kids
no and for everything else we've always
been very instinct but it's just
something about both of you carrying the
weight
yeah and everything has always been just
use that as an example
this is the one area of our marriage
where i'm the only one doing the
grown-up stuff you're doing the grown-up
stuff with me on everything else
and i need you to be the man and walk
beside your woman and we need to be
making good decisions together on money
like we do with the kids like we do on
other things we're so in sync on other
things and there's a point rachel too
that you know if money is not his
strength because that's more me and our
marriage was just so funny like if it
was up to me to literally make sure
every single bill was paid every month
we may be late like one or two times
like winston is just good at it right
like he's just more naturally organized
and all of that so in our marriage you
know now i mean it's been 12 years but
we but we do the budget together but
beforehand he would actually do it to
what your husband's saying hey you do
the budget and then bring it to me and
let's talk about it that's one thing
because i think in marriage that's going
to happen there's going to be one person
that's just naturally good but you guys
agreeing is what's key but what the
problem here here right now is that
you're stuck you can't even create the
budget
because you need more help you need
another brain in the situation so
there's a lot of different angles here
for sure yeah you just this is a
communication marriage issue and it
happens to be around the subject of
money in the budget if you'll treat it
that way i think you'll get a lot
further and bring a third party in if
you need to yeah if you have to sit down
with a good marriage counselor or with a
pastor won't hurt a thing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
mental health
your money your life your careers it's
what we do well ap is reporting a record
31 and a half million americans plan to
bet on this year's super bowl according
to estimates released tuesday by the
gambling industries national trade group
they're so proud the game the american
gaming association forecasted over 7.6
billion dollars
will be wagered on pro football's
championship game set for sunday
both the amount of people planning to
bet up 35 percent last year and the
estimated amount of money being bet
get this
up 78
from last year
are new records
betters include people making casual
wagers with friends or relatives entries
into office pools wagers with licensed
sports books and bets placed with
illegal bookmakers americans have never
been more interested in legal sports
wagering said bill miller the
president's group and ceo of course he
would say that he's somewhat true that's
true by the way i think he's right when
the los angeles rams and cincinnati
bengals begin the game sunday evening in
the rams home stadium 30 states plus
washington d.c will offer legal
gambling
i'm gonna be honest
give me a game of craps in vegas
and i'm like i and like there's a level
of entertainment there for me i just
have zero i don't understand the sports
gambling world
there's nothing entertaining
and like
i mean i guess there's like a social
aspect i just i i just don't
i i don't know i just don't get it
okay
it says the girl who likes to play crap
i know but for me i'm like there's like
this there's this atmosphere there's i
don't know something like about it but
when it just comes to sports gambling
i'm like i'm going to venmo money i'm
going to whatever it's just
there's nothing i don't i just don't
understand it so for me i don't you
don't get gambling period i don't bet
because i don't like to lose i'm too
cheap but the um
but i think what happens is i mean even
friends of mine they'll make a a
friendly wager not on money but on
something else like you have to wear the
wrong jersey the next day or something
like that it just makes you cheer for
your team
that much more and i hate the other team
more or whatever yeah
in the game in a sense yeah but um you
know it makes you pay attention more
it's not just so quote it's not just uh
casual viewing right right uh and then
of course the more you put on it the
more intense
uh you get there i suppose that would be
the uh a reasonable theory by someone
who doesn't do it probably the worst
deal yeah we're the worst ones to
comment on this but what but
what does occur to me is this is that
you know we have a student loan crisis
in america yeah
but we have 7.6 billion dollars being
bet on a football game i mean that's
insane
while well somebody's kids aren't going
to college right right
you know and there'll be people that
lose their homes over this there'll be
people that that are you know way over
the edge i mean they've lost their minds
they're in a gambling addiction mode
um and i don't know what the percentages
are but um
it's a problem and so i don't know what
percentage of this is casual ten dollar
and fifty or a hundred dollar betting
versus somebody betting a hundred
thousand or ten thousand that is you
know they're betting their 401k or
something on a football game well and
it's bizarre how much it's gone up
though i mean yeah
seventy eight percent about the amount
of money because you think through well
all you gotta do is watch if you've been
watching football you know it's the
sports betting's gone up because every
commercial is fanduel and caesar and i
see caesar one more time i'm gonna punch
the guy but uh it's a horrible
commercial but um
but the uh uh
the ads it's that but you know and if
they're dropping that kind of money in
that kind of venue on advertising that
means they're making
nice
the gambling industry is really good at
sucking you into gambling yep and uh
and you know
uh
the idea that you're betting money while
you're broke in debt your kids don't
have the college funded and you've got a
car payment uh
that makes you look pretty stupid yeah
it makes you look pretty stupid and so
that means there's a whole bunch of
people i'm listening to us right now i
just called them stupid
you know i really did and they are you
are if you're doing that well you're
yeah you're not stupid but your activity
is stupid this is a stupid idea
um just like a stupid idea to go buy a
lotto ticket you know and now you you
probably got a better actual probability
of winning something here than you do
with lotto statistically speaking yeah
but uh but
not based on the fact that you're the
best world's best sports gamer because
you're because i mean i feel like our
stance your i'll just say my stance is
if you get to a point where you are
gambling there's such risk involved that
you have to be at a point it's almost to
me even like a bitcoin conversation like
if you are completely debt-free you have
your emergency fund you're funding your
retirement you're running against
college and you have a little small
percentage of your world over here that
you kind of you're willing to lose
you're willing to lose you could burn it
and it doesn't affect you're willing to
lose it for the thrill and it's there
and that's where you're choosing to kind
of entertain then you know what i mean
at that point it's kind of like some
people buy a boat
some people buy
whatever for for the recreation and this
is recreational sure
gaming at that point but yeah the amount
of money in the amount of people 31 31.5
million americans are betting that's
like everybody it's just a lot
it's a lot of you guys so where billion
dollars
is wagered
that's i wonder why to the money so
people people are willing to spend more
right now in life anything i feel like
whether it's houses or cars or travel or
food like people are just well inflation
too but like people are just spending
more
and there's still this this effect of
the pandemic i swear the 2020 you're all
cooped up 2021 you're still kind of
walking on eggshells but you're getting
there and it's almost like we hit 2022
and it's just like everyone's just
screaming for normalcy again
and it's like all the pent up tension
still is is being
released
in life and part of it i'm like i just
wonder if that's part of it too like the
amount of the 78 percent more being
better than last year
that's so that's crazy yeah so i don't
know it's a it's a huge increase part of
this though is the marketing and the
advertising is driving it because
they're talking people into betting yeah
that never would have thought of it
before second thing is there's a real
get rich quick vibe going on in america
right now yeah that's fair yeah this is
a sense of
a shortcut i'm looking for a shortcut
i'm looking for a shortcut i'm looking
for an easy money and uh and you know
the ultimate in arrogance is thinking
you're going to win
you know that you've got something
figured out you've got an edge you've
figured out the pattern you figured out
how this is going to work yeah and
that's just so laughable yeah that um
you know i played the odds and i won the
last five games and so now i'm going to
double down you know yeah that's just
laughable that's that's but but um
the
the sad thing is is in the wake of this
there's two things two types of people
playing ones that are gonna lose
everything
um and i don't know what percentage that
is but we all know they're there
and with that kind of increase you're
going to see an increase in that
ratio wise perception wise
the next thing you're going to run into
is that there's a lot more is that
basically you have a lot of people who
really don't have money to lose that are
going to lose it
meaning you lose 500 bucks and you've
got a car payment you don't have that
money to lose yeah you lose 500 bucks
and you're still sitting with a student
loan or your kid's student loan is or
kid student college loan college
fund is not funded then you know you
don't have money to lose
and you know you're you're gambling away
your family's
good the prosperity of your family then
and that's you don't have that money and
we know a large percentage of these
people even casual batters yeah fall
into that
and so
um
you know it's just uh there's some
devastating numbers that that come out
of this it's just the ripple effect of
it i think the first time i saw this big
time was when i was following the
bankruptcy statistics so closely
um this was 20 years ago the number one
county for bankruptcy filing in the
united states at that time
was
shelby county memphis tennessee and what
happened was and it had just erupted it
had just become that it was the number
four county or number five county before
that and it had become that but it was
tied to the fact that tunica is just
south of there and the casinos had been
put into tunica
and uh a lot of uh lower income people
out of memphis were traveling down to
tunica and losing what they didn't even
have to lose
and so that was true and lotto gets
placed into
lotto as well yeah yeah the
scholarship this direct correlation
between the casino the lower
socioeconomic demographic and now a
bankruptcy statistic that is number one
in the nation and this is the kind of
stuff it's a pain statistic yeah and
that's what you're going to see around
this it's just sad this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 4 25
let your eyes look directly forward and
your gaze be straight before you
albert einstein said life is like riding
a bicycle to keep your balance you must
keep moving boy that's the truth there
is something to be said about moving
forward and that way there's a there's a
sense of balance to things when you
move
forward so do it rachel cruz ramsey
personality is my co-host today olivia
is with us in wisconsin hi olivia
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hi rachel thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
i had a question about saving for my
down payment on a house
currently i've had a mutual fund for the
past 10 years and it's got about 50k
in it should i keep putting money into
my mutual fund and then use that for my
down payment or should i be putting it
in something else
i plan on
buying a house within a year
within the year
i mean yeah
how much do you need for the down
payment
um i'm not sure yet i don't i don't know
i'm trying to get the biggest down
payment possible good for you
it's great
i mean i just pile it in that mutual
fund
when you get ready buy a house just
casey mutual fund out
okay
um
is the mutual fund been doing okay is it
stable uh yeah it's been pretty stable
okay
it's been getting about like 20
i think that's pretty stable yeah that's
pretty stable um what fun does it have
what fun is it
uh parnassus endeavor fund
okay i don't know the fund okay doesn't
mean anything because i don't know that
many mutual funds but um okay just what
i would do is look at the track record
of it and say okay out of the past 10
years how many
years has it lost money how many years
has it made money if it's lost money
five of the 10 i might not put money in
that but if it's lost money one time out
of 10
years i'd go and put money in it because
your chances of losing very much is very
low and your chance of making some money
is good
okay i also had another question on
after i bought the house so i had a
discussion with my boyfriend and
my goal is to pay the house off in
six years by the time i'm 30 but
he thinks that we would just
do the 15-year fixed minimum payments
and then just put money in mutual funds
because
um we'd earned more money that way and
i'm not sure whose idea is better okay
let's start with there's not a we it's a
you because you own the house he doesn't
own the house
right okay but then we can discuss the
theory rachel yeah and the theory
mathematically when you play it out
olivia
for sure can swing the way he's saying
it mathematically but when you're
just doing math you're not equating
life
and everything else that goes so when
something hits like a pandemic and
you're sitting in a paid for home
with money in the bank
you're going to be a lot less stressed
than if you
have a mortgage and all this other stuff
attached to it right so so the idea of
paying off the home
there's an emotional sense with it that
when you pay it off it frees up your
income mathematically so you can
actually put more money in investments
at that point but also you have a paid
for house when you don't have a house
payment you don't owe anyone anything
it changes your perspective it changes
your risk and there's something about it
so
mathematica if you played out his theory
all the way
possibly
but then you're adding in the risk and
adding in the fact that you won't have a
house payment that you can actually
throw that mortgage payment back into
investing
jesse's with us in knoxville hi jesse
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so
i'm currently attending an online school
as an accounting major
i just started my third year and i'm
really not retaining anything and i
think it's mainly like the format of the
classes because i'm not you know there's
not a professor in front of me teaching
it's mainly videos and textbook readings
um so my wife and i have kind of platted
around the idea of me transferring uh to
a college in the area one you're a big
fan of and
we think that would help but the main
drawback to that
is my tuition would go up
pretty substantially
my tuition right now is pretty cheap we
can pretty much cash flow it um
but where i'd transfer it would go up um
by about five thousand dollars a year
and i just don't know if that's a good
idea and i wanted your take
how much do you guys make jesse what's
your household income
uh about 60 000.
okay
i mean the college investing investing
in education all of that i mean it's a
it's a debate people have so i mean when
if you
are what you're going to college for is
to learn a skill to go and make more
money on the marketplace right so if
you're not learning
where you are right now then yeah i
think that that's that's an issue
um because you're not going necessarily
to get a specific diploma from a
specific school it's just the fact that
you want to be in person learning is
that right
yeah i i just want to be able to retain
information and learn it's
yeah pretty much so are you your your
goal though is to become a
cpa yes sir okay
all right well you're not going to pass
the cpa if you haven't retained the
information
that's a good point
and you're not going to move into that
field if you haven't retained the
information so you've got to retain the
information
if this methodology isn't working you
have to try a different methodology now
it may mean you slows down how
as an adult learner how long it takes
you to get your accounting degree
uh it might take longer
because you don't have the time because
you're working extra job to pay cash for
the extra cost of the extra tuition
uh but that's okay i would do that
before i would waste my money because
basically it's what you're doing now if
you're not able to retain it
um okay and and you know i i you know
obviously university of tennessee as
you're talking about there in knoxville
is a great school both rachel and i
graduated from there with four-year
degrees
mine was in
mine was in um
uh in finance and hers is in
communication so uh you know we're
we're balls and we're university of
tennessee fans and i think it is a val
of you know i think it's worth the money
you spend to get an accounting degree at
any state school including university of
tennessee so and it's right there in
your neighborhood you don't have
anything now you may have to look at uh
your you know your career change you may
have to work some different jobs or
extra jobs or something in order to be
able to pay for it to go on through
the other thing you could do is there's
other in-person learning in that
community that's even cheaper
i mean pellissippi is right there and i
if i remember right it's community
college it's free
i didn't know about that we've we've
only lived here a couple months so i'm
not super familiar okay check out
pellissippi i believe is a community
college and i believe community colleges
are 100 funded in the state of tennessee
now you can double check me on that okay
but that's my understanding and i can't
remember if pellissippi i don't think
they've gone to a four year yet so if
there's another community college in the
area you could consider that to get out
to get some of your basic accounting
under your belt even if you went over to
ut to finish up your last two years or
something like that
um
you could look at that angle but the
online is the issue and it depends on
how these different uh colleges are
reacting to covet as to whether they
push you out of the classroom or not um
and you're you're saying you're
struggling to learn in the online
setting
you're not retaining the information so
you're not to put yourself in a
different setting somehow or another uh
but no it's not it's not justification
to go into debt there's another way to
do it and it's not super five thousand
dollars you can come up five thousand
dollars delivering pizzas door dash
cutting grass i mean your wife nannying
tutoring i don't know whatever it is you
do but there's all kinds of stuff you
can do
uh to add a little bit of income to your
life into your situation and make this
dream happen but it sounds like it's
worth doing rachel yeah oh i think so
for sure and the fact you're not having
to move or anything in pellissippi
didn't think about that but the
community college right on the road so i
know there's others in there yeah too
yeah i just couldn't just like yeah but
to look at your options but i think it's
valid because if you're going to want to
go into a
skill career specifically that's so
tactical like accounting you've got to
know you gotta be able to do accounting
accounting that's right you know it's
not it's not it's not a subjective thing
it's an objective thing it's very
measurable that's what i was thinking i
was like communications i can kind of
kind of be you kind of bs your way
through that i wouldn't say that but i
can figure out how to make it work i
don't know anybody would do anything
like that not as much
now dave math accounting
i can do ah
oh it comes back to that bring it back
comes back to that
uh good job to the folks in the booth
good job rachel this is the ramsey show
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you